تقوى اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
النافذه التي نقدمها لحضراتكم من مقر
المنتدى الاقتصاديه العالمي في منتجع
دافوس السويسري همم هذا اليوم هو اليوم
الرابع قبل الاخير من اعمال هذا المنتدى
وكانت التركيز في اغلبه كالعاده على
القضيه الاوكرانيه والشان الاوكرانيه
الحرب التي تقودها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا وفي
هذا الاطار انتقد الرئيس الاوكراني
بلودميرسيلنسكي تردد المانيا في تزويد
بلاده بدبابات حديثه حديثه من طراز
اليوبارد اثنان طبعا هي من صنع همم
المانيا وقال ان هذا الوقت ليس الوقت
المناسب للتردد وجاء ذلك طبعا خلال دوبتي
همم افطار هذا الصباح على هامش منتدى
دابوس خطب فيها الرئيس ظلنيسكي الموجودين
هنا في دابوس عبر تقنيه الفيديو وايضا كان
لافتا من وقائع هذا اليوم ظهور رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني همم السابق بوريس
جونسون مجددا ايه تشارك في هذه الماذوبه
مادبه الافطار وجاءت على لسانه بعض
التصريحات التي تفيد بانه ينبغي دعم
اوكرانيا ودعم الرئيس الينسكي بما يحتاج
من اسلحه وعتاد حتى يستطيع انجاز المهمه
وقال انه هناك تضاؤل لاحتمالات استخدام
روسيا السلاح النووي التكتيكي ضد اوكرانيا
قال ان هذه مجرد تهديدات جوفا معنا
الان في استوديو التغطيه رئيس الوزراء
الهولندي احد الذين شاركوا في دبدوبه
الافطار اليوم الرئيس الوزراء الهولندي
مرحبا بك سيدي الرئيس الوزراء همم كنتم
حاضرين في مادبه الافطار هذا الصباح وجاء
همم على لسان الرئيس الاوكراني انتقادات
لتلك المانيا في تزويد بلاده
بالدبابات همم ما رايكم في هذا الامر هل
انتم همم تاؤيدون وجهه نظر اوكرانيا في ان
المانيا تتردد وتتلك وان هذا الوقت ليس
مناسبا لهذا
كان فيما يتعلقوا
بالقضايا الرئيسيه الاساسيه هناك طبعا
قضيه كيفيه توصيل الدبابات الاوكرانيا لكن
دبابات من فئه لافاردو 2 هي عليك ان تفعل
ذلك مع اكثر من بلد ومع ذلك عليك ان تجعل
دورا للوراثه المتحده في ذلك هذا النقاش
يدور حاليا لست متاكدا متى
يتم ذلك في اقرب وقت لكن فقط انتقاد
المانيا ليس صحيحا المانيا ومنذ بدايه
الحرب قدمت الكثير من الدعم المالي
والمعدات وايضا والمساعدات ايضا اذا نقول
ان المانيا تلعب دورا رياضيا في هذا
المجال
على حد علمنا ان بلادكم واحدا من البلدان
القليله التي تملك هذه المنظومه المتطوره
من الدبابات ليوبارد افنان هل انتم
مستعدون اذا وافقت المانيا غدا في
الاجتماع المقرر في رانشتاين على تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات هل انتم مستعدون
لتقديمها ايضا لاوكرانيا من مخزونكم
طويل معنا لكنها ليست مملوكه ويمكن ان
نقدمها
انظر الى المساله من ناحيه دبلوماسيه كيف
يتصرف الحلفاء هل سيكون هناك دور لامريكا
او لا هل ستقبل المانيا بالخطوه التاليه
ربما كلما قل الحديث عن ذلك علنا كلما كان
الافضل
واذا ما استطعنا نساعد في اي طريقه سواء
بالتدريب او نحو ذلك لن نتاخر
عقب لقائكم بالرئيس الامريكي قبل يومين
ذكرتم انكم على استعداد لتزويد او تعهدتم
في الحقيقه بتزويد اوكرانيا بمنظومه
بيتريوت الدفاعيه الصاروخيه او المضاده
للطائرات والصواريخ المتطوره يعني السؤال
هل هذه العروض وهذه المساعدات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا يفترض انها تجري وفقه
استراتيجيه عسكريه محدده لتحقيق النصر في
نهايه المطاف لحليفكم الاوكراني هل
تعتقدون في نجاعه هذه الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم
انت لن تحصل الى مرحله النصر من خلال فقط
الدعم بجانب معين نحن مع الولايات المتحده
ومع المانيا نعم بشكل مشترك لنرى ما هي
المعدات التي ستنفع ليس فقط من ناحيه
التدريب بل من كل النواحي الاخرى طبعا من
الضروري والحيويه ان تفوز اوكراني في هذا
الحرب في هذه الحرب هذه نقطه مهمه لاننا
نعلم من دروس التاريخ بانها روسيا اذا ما
استطعت ان تدخل وتسيطر على اوكرانيا خطتها
لا تنجح حاليا لكن لو نجحت في ذلك من
دوننا نحن ان نتصدع ونقاتل نحن
الاوكرانيين فلم نستطيع ايقافهم ستكون
هناك دوله اخرى دوله اخرى وبعد ذلك سيؤثر
هذا في كل العالم بما في ذلك الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا في لتصبح كلها اقل امنا وامانا
الانباء القادمه من الولايات المتحده تشير
الى ان البنتاجون في تقييمه لما يجري في
اوكرانيا يرى ان احتمالات استخدام الرئيس
الروسي لازم يفوت لاسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه ضد
القوات الاوكرانيه هو احتمال محدود يكاد
يكون متضائل للغايه هل تقيمكم للوضع على
نفس الشاكله
ما اعتقد ان التونتاجون له وجهه نظر نافعه
هنا وايضا فيما يتعلقوا بجعل الاسلحه
النوويه من جانب روسيا كجزء من جدليه هذه
الحرب هذا يعني ان روسيا تخسر الحرب لانهم
لو كانوا حقا يحققونا النصر والتقدم فلن
يتحدث عن استخدام السلاح النووي لذلك
نصيحه علينا جميعا ان نتجاهل هذا الكلام
نتعامل بشكل منطقي وعقلاني وبشكل المفتوح
ليست لدينا قوات على الارض لكن وليس لدينا
قتال مفتوح مع روسيا لكن نساعد
الاوكرانيين في حربها
يعني اوكرانيا ليست عضوا في حلف شمال
الاطلسيته وليست عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ما معنى تزويدها او تزويدها بكل هذه
النوعيه من الاسلحه المتطوره غير انها هذه
هي التعريف او هذا هو التعريف للحرب
بالوكاله التي توجه روسيا الاتهامات
بشانها للغرب والتحالف الغربي برمته
الله يحفظك بالوكاله كانت روسيا هي التي
بدات هذه الحرب ضد بلد له سيادته
وهوكرانيا لن نقبل هذا في العالم المعاصر
لاننا اذا قبلنا بذلك كل العالم سيفقد
امنه وامامه لابد لنا من ان نقاتل هذه
الاوكرانيا
لكن لا تصدقوا سرديات الروس هذه محاوله من
بلد للسيطر على بلد اخر وهذا موجود من قبل
الخمسينيات والستين ياتمر صار من الماضي
لن نراه في العالم المتحضر علينا انه كافح
هذا الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس الوزراء الهولندي مارك
روتا على هذا الحوار شكرا لك